another movie review yeah this is a good
one this was the frighteners yes Tom why
doesn't want to do this one for a long
time does I really like this movie one
of my favorite movies I actually saw
this in the theater when it came out
yeah and it was the only guy that
theater 1996 1996 yeah it's good it
didn't do that well at the box office
was a shame it was yeah well it's it
came out the same time as like
Independence Day which of course was a
huge huge success um you know it opened
the same days like the olympics and [ __ ]
like that so I think another problem was
is that this was a foreign film and a
lot of people didn't know it this is
Peter Jackson's first big-budget
big-budget flick Hollywood film yeah and
it's not really an American movie it's
New Zealand yeah it was shot in New
Zealand and like I said this was kind of
the transition film for Peter Jackson
prior to this film which came out in
1996 he had done mostly indie flix you
know Dead Alive he had done Heavenly
Creatures
at but after this one and actually this
is the movie on which he set up the
digital effects studio that would later
on go on to do the Lord of the Rings
without this movie there probably have
not been to the Lord yeah so now it
should be said that like I said 1996
digital effects were very much in their
infancy they didn't really know much
about them so there are a lot of digital
effects in this actually I think prior
to this this was kind of the movie that
had the most digital effects in it for
the time yeah you know so they don't
look fantastic today because you know it
was the early 90s but this is really
have to though they know not really you
know what you know the tone of this
movie is I like the tone this movie how
do you see it and it's almost kind of
like a dark version of Back to the
Future where it's a weird mixture of
happy and sad at the same time yeah fun
and sad at the same time response um
Ghostbusters kind of yeah vibe to it -
right so the CGI heard people complain
about it at the time but I saw that you
know when I saw it I was like yeah
but you know what it's just a fun movie
and it's not a look I would classify it
as probably a dark comedy yeah because
it's funny but I mean it's Peter Jackson
and he tends to do I mean there's quite
a bit of gore in it yeah he actually
tried to restrain the gore but it still
ended up getting an R rating yeah I have
the extended director's cut of this yeah
all right which it just came out on
blu-ray last night was the first time I
saw the extended cut yeah and the movies
actually a lot better I liked it better
with the additional with the additional
stuff left in it's 12 to 14 minutes
longer yeah and it's a little over two
hours and it really kind of fleshes out
the story and the characters a bit more
oh I forgot to mention patreon is back
to normal yeah alright so we lost a
couple of patrons with this weird change
that they yeah we think well they
announcement that they made that they
were gonna change the feed structure or
whatever we ended up I think we ended up
losing three but then some of the other
patrons you know up there support which
is much appreciated or some move to
PayPal which is totally fine right you
know like I said patreon sent a message
that since there were so many complaints
at the announcement that they weren't
going to change the fee structure
everything was going to remain the same
so you know so don't worry about that
hate Rihanna almost turned itself into
another MySpace yes they don't have a
monopoly on this well yeah there's other
ones you saw you and I think a lot of
people threatened to leave yes it was
just a bad idea if patreon needed more
money they should have taken it from us
not from them not from the patrons yeah
yeah you know they should have asked for
a couple more percentage from us but
they you know so anyway if you find
patreon more convenient you guys want to
go back to patron patreon you can yeah
it's the same as it was or like I said
if you'd rather do PayPal we have a we
have a PayPal link also so you know
whichever any support is appreciated and
we understand if people don't like
patreon for whatever reason even though
they're not going to change the fee
structure now so we just thought we'd
mentioned that I know we mentioned it
other review but we're not sure which
we're gonna put these up in so right
yeah
or three shows today so yeah we're gonna
put them on at all we don't know which
ones going on for it yes so we just I
thought we would mentioned that again so
now let's get back to the frighteners
that we just watched this last night I
saw it two years ago was the last time I
self but that was the theatrical cut and
like you said the director's cut adds I
think it's it's either 12 minutes or 14
minutes footage closer to me and I
actually even though it's longer it's a
little over two hours now I think it
actually the pacing is better yeah yeah
so the characters are fleshed out more
yeah there are a little more develop out
more about Special Agent Milton Danvers
Dammers yeah and of course you know he's
played by Jeff recalls oh my god but
[ __ ] weird this movie has an awesome
cast actually really the Michael J Fox
as Frank Bannister who's a paranormal
investigator yeah but he can actually
see and talk to ghosts and as a result
13 o'clock you know two covers a lot of
paranormal yes subjects and really this
movie even though it's kind of a kind of
a horror comedy or comedy has a lot of
good paranormal ideas in it yeah that
talks about near-death experiences ACOG
talks about forcing an out-of-body
experience
ghosts and how ghosts and spirits relate
to each other that some ghosts are
stronger than other ghosts lee ermey is
one of the ghosts he's the guy who from
Full Metal Jacket you know he's in the
cemetery keeping order and he's dressed
as a drill sergeant
he's dressed as whatever he needs for
any kind of mission get back at your
graves things must be contained I mean
he's a great character and you know he
goes I'm not one of your shitty
emanations yeah because he's actually
strong at the punch people and some
can't and depending on their I guess
their willpower some ghosts are kind of
like rotting and falling apart you know
their ectoplasm is driven but not Lee a
melee army looks bright shiny and brand
new he wasn't fall apart yeah the same
thing with the with the big villain
again in the flick hoo
a serial killer in the afterlife
continuing his mission the carnage upon
people yeah he's not sure he's not
falling apart either Mac he's an awful
monster I kind of feel like this kind of
uses the same premise or similar premise
- like Beetlejuice where if you're a new
ghost you have to like learn how to do
[ __ ] yeah thank you like they couldn't
touch things that you know but you have
to learn that like the longer your dad
you figure stuff out so it's a similar
kind of yeah they were they were
figuring things out - but it also looked
like somebody's force of will
yeah it could make any stronger makes a
stronger or weaker yeah if the Sun were
just being contained remember right so
we're just being contained in the
cemetery some of them are falling apart
like when Lucy's husband when he dies he
immediately starts falling apart
remember that right and within a few
days yeah and you know and he's he's
like a dweeb II mean he's a dweeb who
thinks he's a meathead yeah okay yeah
and what's cool about the flick you know
Bannister is uh he kind of has a weird
past where his wife died you know and a
car wreck that he was and Michael J Fox
does a great job with this character I
like this character because Michael J
Fox I mean he usually plays like super
goody two-shoes candidate on account of
characters this character is still a
good guy but he's darker and he's some
kind of a more grey area he's kind of I
don't want to call him a conman because
I mean he's kind of portrayed as he's
conning people but there is apparently
yes so he is a psychic he can see ghosts
but his whole shtick is that he's
friends with ghosts he sends ghosts to
people's houses yeah to [ __ ] [ __ ] up so
then he gets hired to go get rid of them
right so in that way he is conning
people Rekha's he's responsible for the
hospital right but he but he is actually
a second in care and so he's not a con
man in that yeah he's got a gang of
ghosts that he doesn't really doesn't
wanna take the story how he got in
contact Lee's ghost but he's see ghosts
so I guess he just recruited him yeah
there's three of them one of them is the
judge and he they're talking about Roy
Bean he's an old cowboy who's falling
apart he's played by John Astin John
Gomez from the original axe
another one's another one is is Cyrus
the Cyrus is kind of like a 1970s
blaxploitation pimp gangsta type guy
yeah he's got a big afro got a big afro
he's dressed like from the 70s that's
one of the he's one of the frighteners
and the other ones did a little nerdy
college student from the 20s named
Stuart yeah who evidently killed himself
because he's got a he's got a scar
around his neck like he hung himself
so Frank sends his team of frighteners
to houses that he targets and usually
they get involved with the kids you know
the frighteners do they get the kids in
on it little babies which you'll see and
they start all this poltergeist activity
throwing things and banging the toilet
seats and they'll also drop Frank's card
yeah yeah so they'll call him for help
and that Frank will go down there and go
through a big rigmarole you know the old
toaster toaster it's an old radio yeah
it looks like an old radio it's like a
little toaster popping yeah a squirt gun
full up give him this big line about
yeah yeah are spk blond ghosts and
emanations and bullet here I'll suck him
right into this contraption here and
we'll unique tries to throw him down the
garbage disposal you know likes like
from what he saw out of ghostbusters
actually that's what he's trying to do
like he's trying to put them into like a
containment unit and then it pops him
out in a little bag that he's gonna
destroy them around he's charging him
for extra for disposal and also like I
said I I liked that there were things in
it that made him less than sympathetic
like at one point you see him at a
funeral like going around to the
mourners like giving his card to people
it's like he's gonna send the
frighteners to the house right and and
you know and reason why he needs this
money he needs $13,000 to continue the
construction of his dream house he was
at one time an architect yeah before the
car accident yes that was in the car
drinking and arguing with his wife he
ran the car off a road and wiped that
kill yeah so he went into a depression
and he was never able to complete the
house and that's what made him be able
to see go shouldn't see goes before no
he had a near-death experience and after
that he could see ghosts yeah well
eventually went to what ends up
happening is that a bunch of people in
town start mysteriously having these
heart attacks yeah like young healthy
people yeah they're not supposed to be
dying and what's weird is that they die
around Frank yeah and the police call in
a special investigator from the FBI says
Geoffrey calls and you find out some
weird stuff about him in the extended
version I don't think I should spoil it
you probably shouldn't because I like he
is weird a character he is in the
theatrical version like I can't remember
exactly what they added but I know a lot
of it with what they add and what they
added to Dammers if you've seen the
original is that he says I always have
to deal with the freaky cases yeah okay
well he gives the details in this very
explain a lot of the backstory of that
he worked on them on the Manson murder
yes okay he worked in a couple of
different cults that did weird [ __ ] yeah
and and you find out that that made him
immune to physical pain and torture he
had unlimited willpower yeah and when
you hear his story about how many years
of what these cults are were doing and
what they were making him seriously like
yes I did it for my country and all its
kind of second and he was gather he's
creepier when you find out that that
exact sorry yeah and I like that they
went more into it because I loved it
Jeffrey Combs is just he's so [ __ ]
great and this it's just he's so over
the top weird that it's just I mean I
love him anyway like it's good and
everything but you find out why he's
weird yeah but he's just like super
super creepy that is so great
which it's funny because I think that
was kind of there wasn't that use this
film was actually pretty positively
reviewed when it came out but I think um
a couple of the complaints people had
was that oh that the tone was strange
you know what I made it kind of had it
was a comedy but then it had like all
this gore and then it had like all these
creepy elements but I don't know I think
that well it's nice I didn't find it
strong what happened what happens is I
think when people go in the movie not
knowing anything about it just yet dead
especially the theatrical version of it
I think it it's kind of like shocking
because there's comedy and there's weird
stuff happening at the same yeah but
after you see it like twice you're like
okay I get it and I think that that was
another thing that Peter
Jackson said even at the time and he
might have said it later too is that
he's like I felt like they didn't know
how to market it right it is a very
weird movie to market it's not a horror
movie it's not a straight comedy either
I don't think it got any I don't think
it got any promotion to speak of because
when I did but the promotion was
terrible it kind of portrayed it like a
[ __ ] I'll tell you how I found this
movie all right I got off work late in
Boston
working out go Wellesley doing my sales
right I was a Salesman at that time and
in a way I was kinda like Frank bastard
[Laughter]
yeah so anyway um sales is a tough
business Glengarry Glen Ross so I'm
coming back late and I don't really want
to go to the apartment it was live in
Boston at the time and I saw it there
was a movie theater there and it said
the frighteners rated R Michael J Fox
and I said oh Michael J Fox and I love
back to the future so I just went dead
I'm just it was probably like on a
Wednesday or Thursday night you know
prior round six six in the evening it
was already dark so I find out that this
is a movie about ghosts and stuff so so
this might be might be interesting so I
went in and I was the only kind of
theater yeah I loved the film though man
this is awesome this is awesome but I
had never I didn't even see a single
trailer or anything just just well I
seem to remember like I remember seeing
commercials for this and trailers for
this in the 90s and I feel like the
trailers made it look like a straight
horror movie I could be remembering that
wrong but I do remember thinking that it
was a horror movie not that it was a
comedy I remember going to see it just
because they had Michael J Fox in it how
did you hear that hair if it was a
comedy or or I was just want to kill
time yeah I loved it I'd already been
through my own experience you know they
talked about mammoth mountain I was just
I can kind of relate to it yeah
out-of-body experiences and near-death
experiences and told you guys and I was
just like yeah you know I can it's a
very mainstream interpretation of it
yeah it's it's quite cool you know
especially you see ghosts interacting
with each other there are ghosts I think
maybe ghosts are like what Windish
Freight when he dies or has his
near-death experience and he goes
through the tunnel and stuff you know I
think most people when they die that's
what happens to them but that's what's
supposed to have it's kind of a good
description yeah one it's an alternate
theory what's happening well doesn't
okay
isn't there one point like when Lucy the
main doctor in the movie you know and
the kind of the love interest now her
husband dies yeah and then the ghost
like contacts Frank yeah and is asking
what now doesn't Frank explain because
some people when they die they just go
right up into the tongue yeah I may go
to heaven or whatever right but some
people hang around you're right and it
isn't there some kind of rule where if
you don't go up in the tunnel
immediately then you there's you're
stuck for about a year Frank Frank tells
us is why didn't you go why didn't you
go to the light yeah ain't you goes the
little light oh oh you know he it's not
my time you know I'm only 29 you know
yeah and he goes okay well then just in
about a year you're you're gonna see the
light again and then you know it'll come
down and you can go yeah take it next
time if not you're gonna be stuck here
you know and he was already starting to
fall apart
yeah that's an ectoplasmic they were
called an ectoplasm yeah it kind of like
sweats out this weird junkie yeah which
is what ended up happening to the judge
Johnson's character I mean he's
obviously been around since the Old West
and he's been stuck on earth since the
Old West so he is all [ __ ] up well his
jaw keeps falling off yeah he tells
Frankie says Frank don't tell the other
guys but Magda plasm is all dried up
yeah everything he says is a sexual
innuendo
also how often do you get to see John
Astin in old people ghost makeup humping
a mummy oh yeah yeah there's a scene
that takes place in in a museum and he
sees that Mommy in there and he goes oh
[Laughter]
yeah and then like another another one
of the things that they added was pretty
cool you know Frank's in his uncle in
uncompleted house yeah yeah trying to
take a shower and yelling at the ghosts
of Cyrus
gangster goes pops up out of the drain
looking at him looking straight up at
him from between his legs this how's it
hanging Frankie because you tell me as
if girls ain't missing nothing yeah you
know cuz I'm gonna take a piss and I'm
not gonna get out of the shower I'm out
of here Frank I like like the added
interactions yeah it was actually very
yeah it kind of rounds it out a little
bit yeah I feel like maybe two Americans
this tone is weird or something like
that but I feel like movies made in
Australia and New Zealand and stuff like
that
this kind of thing is more common the
kind of raunchy humor and horror kind of
coexisting with the comedy yeah I feel
like they're kind of more down with that
that American movie was very underrated
yeah area under 80 it's it's a super
super fun yeah and you know and
basically basically towards the end of
it or towards the middle of it Frank is
getting the rap for all these murders
because he always seems to be a one
seems to round yeah especially agent
Dammers thinks that Frank is killing
these people with psychokinesis yeah
okay well uh and he's not aware of a
spirit world where there's this ghost of
a serial killer murdering people
so Frank basically has to escape from
jail to get this mission done I'm not
gonna I don't want to spoil too much
about what happens to the frighteners
Frank has to go toe to toe with a dead
serial killer to do this he has to
induced an out-of-body experience yeah
you know he first was gonna try to do it
by putting a bullet through his head
which he is probably not coming back
girl he was trying to help the time
sister who was who was a doctor says no
I got some stuff she injection with some
things with some kind of drug just slow
him down
yeah and she puts him in a freezer and
he goes out for a limited amount of time
and goes a stroll and deals with this
ghost but you know I don't want to get
too much into it I don't want to spoil
this one you know I don't this isn't a
super well-known movie so I don't wanna
yes boil it for the 13 o'clock audience
I know you guys are into paranormal this
is one you should actually see you'll
have a good time it's all rated but it's
by today's standards
I think it's fun for the family yeah I
mean like I said it's it's got some gory
parts and there's a little bit of
raunchy humor in it but I don't think
it's anything that CG gore a lot of
ghosts getting cut in half and ghosts
becoming dusted off into clouds of
ectoplasm yeah you know yeah you
probably don't want like little little
kids watch that but you know I get up
and watch this yeah it's totally fine um
you know I don't think it's any worse
than anything else that came at the time
but one thing I was gonna say that I
actually kind of liked I liked the the
range of types of ghosts yeah in this I
also liked that it had like I said like
it had horror movie elements to it too
there were parts that were actually kind
of scary yeah and I also liked that the
Michael J Fox character was not
portrayed as a total good guy know like
he had some negative qualities in fact
at the beginning of the movie and
probably actually maybe the first fourth
first half of the movie he's not all
that sympathetic I mean he kind of is
cuz he's the protagonist but you know
you find out things about him that are
kind of like make him less so he's so I
like that he's a more nuanced character
he is I would say he is Marty McFly but
a damaged Marty McFly that's a good way
of putting it yeah a little bit more
believable yeah then he gets depressed
he kind of gets you know certainly
suicidal during his interrogation with
the police you can see his face it'sit's
very kind of drawn and dark you know
yeah it's good
the Fox did a fantastic job he's very
good in that it's really good and
actually that was now that was one of
the scenes that got added right the
whole thing about the interrogation
scene is longer death the interrogation
scene is longer and isn't there a point
where he gets to where he can't see the
ghosts for a brief - yeah they didn't
include that near room and that wasn't
in the theatrical ride it's like it's
not a huge part of the plot but there is
a little details much little details
about rules about there is a time where
you can't see the ghost for a time and
because and they bring it up it's
because he stopped believing okay
there's this
scene in a potential customers house
where the frighteners are doing their
thing they're terrifying this woman
who's got three babies they're making
the babies fly around the babies are
that [ __ ] yeah they find Frank banisters
card on the ground and the mom calls
Frank to come up to come over and stop
the haunted yeah and in the meantime
while he was driving over there she
finds a newspaper saying that Frank
Bannister was a con a con man there was
a picture taken if I'm at the throttle
early in the movie and when she saw that
it was a con man that she had called The
Haunting stopped yeah Frank shows up on
the scene and he's going through his
spiel as ghostbusters spiel and you see
Cyrus and Stuart the ghost sitting on
the couch going Frank don't worry about
it now it says don't bother and this in
the haunt he has stopped you don't
really know why the haunting is stopped
and you find out later in one of the in
one of the scenes that was you know that
was deleted out of the regular
theatrical cut you find out that a
person has to believe the haunting is
happening or they have to believe that
it's real for a ghost to be able to move
anything yeah which I like that they
kind of clarified that you're right
that's why like I said that's why I like
that they put that scene back in and the
director's cut because it explained why
that particular you know job went wrong
yeah paranormal rules yeah the rules of
paranormal right because it wasn't
really explained in the in the
theatrical cut like why that kind of
like out kind of like quantum physics
it's not there until you look at it in a
scene that was deleted in the ER in the
original theatrical release Cyrus and
Stuart only visit Frank in jail once
yeah in the extended director's cut they
visit twice and the first visit that you
don't see in the normal cut yeah Cyrus
and Stuart visit him in jail and they go
Frank
hey man what's going on we got to spring
you out of here and Frank doesn't
respond they're gonna look at us right
in the end and then circles ha nah okay
never mind
he no longer believes yeah so that was
something that was left out of a
theatrical trailer and the reason that
he lost his belief was because of the
ham
that the FBI agent was giving him yeah
and he kind of made Frank believe for a
little while that he was is
psychokinesis that was killing all these
people it was the one responsible out
there if there were no goes to see go
she had to have faith and belief in a
ghost and then you yes which was kind of
a cool thing and I wish they had left
that in because it explains some stuff
from the beginning and evidently a ghost
can't haunt you a ghost can't move
anything if you don't believe yeah if
you don't believe that that's what it is
that's what it is
yes and like I said I also like that
they added in all this stuff with
Jeffrey Combs character yeah give him
some backstory about why he was such a
[ __ ] where'd ya play and then in a
certain way made him a little bit more
sympathetic it did kind of do hell yeah
because you know you know in the
theatrical cut he's just kind of
portrayed this like a straight-up
villain got a dick yeah he's just a
douche bag right and stuff like that but
no no they kind of give him a history
that makes him a little bit more sip of
that yeah he went through he's still a
villain but yeah horrible [ __ ] went
through a lot of horrible [ __ ] for his
country yeah I got stuff yeah I see
another thing I love about this when I
was watching it I was sitting there
going this there's no way that this was
I know it's supposed to be set in the
United States and all the characters are
American but I was like there's no way
that that's anywhere the United States
where this was filmed and it wasn't it's
Wellington New Zealand but they tried to
make it look like the u.s. just kind of
anywhere USA but you could still tell
that it wasn't but I have to say one of
the coolest things is the house that the
girl Patricia lives in yeah the the you
know the serial killers serial killers
girlfriend Rosen with her old mother
yeah that house is so cool like the
inside that like that red and black
wallpaper it's like very it's very very
cool yeah it's kind of a stereotype
going away kind of like a Disneyland
style looking a haunted house oh yeah
and what's funny is that when a normal
person sees it it's just kind of a
spooky looking house but when Lucy's
when the ghost of Lucy's dead husband
sees it he comes around the corner and
sees that house here's just manoj us
triack's coils from the thing in horror
and when and when you see it from the
eyes of a ghost it's just this big tall
wavery
waving kind of like it's a shivering
yeah house of evil yeah now
well oh that was that was another thing
I was gonna say too is the thing I like
about this is that you know for most of
the movie Michael J Fox is character
Frank Bannister it's the only one that
can see the ghost so if you're looking
like for a lot of these scenes where all
this [ __ ] like all this [ __ ] is
happening but nobody can see it but hmmm
yeah which I'm like it's crazy yeah
which I really really like especially
the scene where in the jail cell where
the two ghosts where Cyrus and Stuart
come and they're trying to fight off the
Grim Reaper very precise yeah and all
this stuff is going on and so Michael J
Fox can see all of it but Lucy can't see
it she's just trying to like just fling
her around the thing and she's like
where are they what's good yeah and
that's like another thing that I made
the very little Stuart Ghost comes in he
jumps in the cell he goes what happens
yeah I think we got him I really do like
that yeah but I have to and another
thing too that that I was gonna say
about Michael J Fox is character being
not hugely sympathetic is he's kind of a
jerk to his ghosts at the beginning yeah
is there supposed to be like Stuart is
like we're supposed to be your business
partners yeah you kind of his treatment
and he kind of this treats him a little
bit like he's kind of like always
busting their chops and it's like why
weren't you guys scary and you guys you
know you didn't even do the toilet thing
well he's always like kind of yelling it
kind of says it's a Cyrus things because
you think you're gonna give me a box of
cigars and he goes what you do cigars
you can't smoke bad [ __ ] you can smoke
em and blow up in my face
he goes if I smoke the cigar I'd be
barred chunks in your face but yeah so
that is another thing that's kind of
cool about the movie like I said they
they weren't afraid to make him less
than sympathetic and it's kind of a jerk
to his I don't think I guess their
employees yeah he's way gonna ride the
truck
yes weeks of riding the truck in a car
and stuff like that and they're all like
they're all butthurt about it yeah it's
pretty funny
but yeah the ghost characters are really
good I want
yeah it's good play you guys haven't
seen it go and check it out yeah it's
good movie and like I said Peter
Jackson's first big-budget like before
he did Lord of the Ring and so kind of
his transition film out of the indie
yeah it's got some pretty cool
interpretations of like paranormal stuff
yeah explanations and different
interpretations of you know in other
words it's it's a good vision of what
many explanations of the paranormal are
and it doesn't and it's done kind of in
a funny way
yeah what's Jacob you see as a serial
killer yeah Jake is a serial killer
ghost anything and he's really good in
this giant giant teeth and he's really
good yeah definitely
recommended if you have not seen it it's
a good one yeah the extended special
edition blu-ray was a 15th anniversary
it's worth picking up I think you can
get it for under about 10 bucks
delivered yeah I'll show you because I
think they did the longer version for
the DVD release so we did we got an
unbeliever I got it on blu-ray
so it's our mainly a DVD in the extended
DVD also yeah I think there might be
yeah I thought the blue baby's worth it
though it's it yeah it looks really nice
it looks it you know so that'll do it
for our latest movie review make sure to
tune in to our regular show on Tuesday
and we will see you next time bye